these Mega soft Lush cinnamon rolls with  brown butter icing are a sweet labor of  love and they're definitely worth it the  dough has a nice balance of rich and  buttery with just the right amount of  sweetness while the brown butter cream  cheese icing is almost toffee like with  a hint of caramel but trust it's not too  sweet I feel like the key to a great  cinnamon roll is the balance of rich in  Sweden not too much of one I mean don't  get me wrong texture is important too a  couple of things I like to do when  making these babies is to add just a  little freshly grated nutmeg to the  dough for a hint of spice another thing  I like to do is pour heavy cream over  the rolls just before baking now I know  you might think they'd come out soggy  but listen the rolls actually turn out  pillowy soft Ultra moist and honestly  they're amazing so for your next  Gathering or if you're down for a  weekend project make these rolls and  don't forget the heavy cream then you  can thank me later